okay good afternoon everyone and welcome
to Ma Council meeting it's great to
everybody together around the room again
and to traverse some of the issues that
we've got before us tonight which are
really important ones I do have an
apology for the lateness from council
Nick grant but I'm not aware of any
other apologies would somebody like to
move that those apologies be sustained
please thank you Doug
seconded sure thank you all those in
favor please say aye
getting the motion is carried
Thank You counselors okay are there any
[Music]
conflicts of interest that counselors or
we're off at this point in time in the
agenda that they need to get clear is
not we'll move on then we'll move on to
the confirmation of the minutes and we
have a number of minutes there to
confirm so would somebody like to
confirm that the minutes of the ordinary
meaning of council out of wednesday dean
ape will be confirmed as true correct
move counselor read of a seconder for
that counselor Phillips thank you all
those in favor or is there any
alteration to that record there's not
what that motion all those in favor
please say aye
dance the motion is carried Thank You
counselors somebody like to move the
confirmation the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of Council held 22
April council make 2 now significance of
Doug grant thank you is there any
operation required to that motion it's
not I'll put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
Danks the motion is carried confirmation
of the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of council how 28 April somebody
like to move the Davis seniors to
incorrect yeah so Dixon
I guess the Bolger thank you any
alteration required to those minutes
there's not what the emotional weighs in
favor please say aye
against the motions carried on for
urgent life business I'm not aware of
any urgent light business that needs to
be table but counsel is there any that
you have does not thank you we'll move
on to item 5 and you have the financial
account down here Thank You Donna do you
want to make any comment to your
discussions or questions so even though
the figures are for the end of March a
lot has happened since then to our
financials so I'll just continue with
the match focus as I have a report later
on talking about future predictions so
the total revenue is lower than budget
by $23,000 with expenses being higher
than budget by 1 million three hundred
and thirty one thousand dollars in an
overall unfavorable variance of 1
million three hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars so revenue is mainly in
line with budgets with the exception of
lower NZTA subsidies expenses are higher
than predicted largely due to the very
flood expenses which have now been
allocated to the respective departments
well most of the departments have been
able to accommodate these expenses
within their current budgets the three
waters and solid waste areas have
incurred a significant amount of these
costs this is due to flooding response
into maintenance cost expenditures along
with the remediation work carried out on
the old landfill sites
so we still would earn discussions with
the National Emergency Management Agency
but these are currently on hold due to
the current law to cope at 19 thank you
Thank You Donna okay so counselors open
for discussion
[Music]
you say Stuart yeah I mean Donna other
financial liabilities in the balance
sheet have gone up a million just under
a million dollars does that jutsu
interests walk just rates reducing
therefore the swaps more effectively
more expensive I believed so it's just
due to the timing of it so that would
have been what was it's 30 June last
year and then what we've got now yeah
because the cars interest rates keep
reducing the slots keep becoming more
and more expensive to us too because
they're there it affects right and the
right go stay out here yeah as a million
dollars we've incurred in the year yeah
that's a significant amount of money
these interest swaps cost us but we'll
discuss that later when we come to the I
want to discuss that a lot further when
we come to the discussion on the swaps
and stuff they think that's what I've
got coming help those a legacy I
understand and so they've been being in
place for quite some time and we're
still doing them they did what a match
sorry so ok council hosted do you want
to make a comment there yep probably
just a comment in relation to this has
been discussed or at Risk Committee we
have my financial policy that requires
us to write the appropriate appropriate
sorry the policy was reviewed last year
but I'm guessing Stewart's going to
probably ask the right question things
have changed a lot time to rewrite again
so we'll get to that later on we being
court report questions just yeah agreed
thank you well Jason thank you you
worship thanks Donna I don't know
whether this is the appropriate time
that I was looking at some of the things
in the schedule the why cake a stream
lien Phil you know some of the
apparently there is samples sent off to
a lab for testing and I wondered what
had come back from that from the old
landfill site sorry there wouldn't be a
question for me that would be for the
infrastructure no worries yep thank you
it was just that it was sudden you're an
emotional record so just just all around
that ramesh is there a comment on that
yeah thank you much nothing interesting
before we do the remediation work at the
Vikas stream landfill area that was
required part of the remediation program
we have undertaken it and then based on
the outcome of that we are trying to
implement that procedure to comply with
the es guidelines so we haven't had a
response is that were on here response
from where so you ask the question
Brahmin tasting the contaminants I think
there are some asbestos and other
contaminants are there I think we did
get a report I think
I have the copy of that report that is
why we had to follow a different
protocol to store it and before we take
you to the Anoka Gill landfill area okay
so Peter d1 might come with you
it was initial testing down or visual
sight before we start shifting around
maybe was lowly also this is
contaminants on me about save not first
to work with any ways to eventually
taken from mutual sight we got stored on
the site missed three sites so you saw
it has actually got a storage area so
that material and a self is going to
actually be tested before we decide what
to do ever moment looks like it's pretty
low contaminant and we're going to have
to be able to cover it we're going to be
able to cover it over it but the testing
will be done on that material and if it
is too contaminated it will be taken to
a secure site and enable I'm so the
testing of the material we've taken out
is to each be done so other questions
around this financial report there's no
capital expenditure on the writing
program is progressing but 65 percent of
volcanic offenders spent permanent
structures now almost complete I presume
the budget for capital expenditures
around include the old price for the
brush and so there's some of that 65
percent will never get to a hundred
percent say right and it will be great
yeah thank you right thank you other
questions queries does not what
something like to move that the risk be
received wait traces where I'm sorry
don't get in see there's more hate my
electronic enraged will do it push it
push awesome forgot us in what we be
because the draft the draft district
plain civil defense Klein is sitting in
this report can we
you want to discuss that later can you
discuss this yeah because there's a
question in the morning there's no no
reason why it can't be discussed now the
claim is the claim we're talking about
here the claim you understand that has
been that's on hold Donna's a and
through the Cobie process yes so we've
been in discussions with Rob rouse who's
our context yet and he is busy with
covert 19 so hopefully in the next
couple of weeks we'll be able to resume
those talks okay as he my wish was
around the subtotal estimated cost of
just the Gaul info and the material in
so it's we've got an 80 to 150 dollars
and that's work includes the consulting
engineering and survey project
management services do we
we've got planners within the counsel
Steve might answer this one we've got
cleaning planners that such as Dean
Vulcan and whatever and there's a new
planner come on board does that beyond
year extent of what they do to
preparation for the resource conceits
because consultancy fee is somewhere
between 80,000 Steve doing yeah I can't
make a comment into the the competency
of staff you know I can show you that a
confident bear in mind this work was
came here this like literally as a
tsunami of issues that were were
confronted with and so yeah our
engineering team what you find is that
they've found some of the work out to a
consultancy and would that consultancy
comes a planning
as well so it's very difficult for not
as efficient having someone doing some
design work for example from a civil
engineering company and oftenly these
companies will have a planning staff
in-house that works with them
hand-in-hand to actually deal with all
aspects of the project so it's probably
why there's presidency the way it is it
would be a bit unusual and probably
somewhat messy to have the engineering
design prepared by an outside
consultancy and the planning function
being staff okay thanks Steve
just my other question your worship was
complete remissions this so is this
gonna be a permanent fix for the waiheke
stream who was this temporary because
we're paying for what guell infill is
seven to nine hundred fifty Easter man
and the material was 204 so is this a
just a permanent fix or the team prefix
or what's the worst thing three
ownership I think at this moment we have
planned for a temporary fix has done'
you did and steve mentioned about that
the cost of the planning as per the
funding policy of NEMA agency if we use
our in household so resources those time
staff times are not recoverable and
these are the quantum of the clay we are
trying to produce it if we are able to
manage within our team conscious
resources
I think they expect that to happen
because not compromising the existing
services all the service deliverables so
we have produced a quantum of claim
where we included lot of cost associated
with consultants
consulted as a none required basis we're
realities are seriously required
majority of projects are managed by
Peter in-house and some areas Hashim is
involved in that quantum of claims
submitted is assuming that we can reduce
our staff and keep focus of our staff
with normal services that is another
thing and as regards to your question
about this estimated claims are produced
based on the point contractors estimate
for temporary fix or interim fix so
sorry I just jump in three six
so with that response Ramesh thank you
just going back to the the nature of
team presuppose determined so the
inference I guess here is that temporary
is something that has to be done again
will completed later on is that the case
here or is this something that is
substantially completed I think in my
view I think the way we I think the way
we are progressing it may look like a
little long-term solution but still we
have to do some leachate assessment so
we at this moment we are unable to say
this is a permanent solution if there is
another hook associated with that is if
we consider this as a permanent solution
we cannot claim it to the NEMA funding
areas for NEMA funds only like - like
replacement of the existing landfill
there an equation that so Niki here the
question yeah I touch it towards the
into the report under the liabilities
this comment that it borrowing has risen
by five point five million from last
year no breakdown of what that entails
it's donna able to give us a breakdown
of what they're actually consists of
place not at this point in time
we have uploaded a little bit in March
and that was mainly for the building
upgrade and also for the pyramid bridge
work that have been done to date yeah
just on there it would have been good to
see a breakdown of what that 5.5 million
was made up of just so we can see that
we're on track with all their projects
and how we're actually progressing with
you with their projects so can I ask
that that be done and the next report
that we actually see what bits
what bit in terms professionally I can
look into that for you for the next
report I did thanks Tracy you're just
referring to what remission said about
the transfer the the monitor is there
going to be have to have extra
monitoring it at these sites on the
religious rubbish all those type
material matera and one ago oh okay who
you worship the landfill all the old
landfill requires providing the evidence
that there is nothing obnoxious leaching
into the stream I think that is the
requirement I think which we will
monitor eventually right so that we
further monitoring at those three sorts
an extra cot yeah okay thanks he thinks
you were just just three here question
time just following on from Nicky's
question we we borrowed in advance due
to the interest rate differential I see
we've got about three million dollars in
cash cash equivalents donor we store
this thing against Airlines or is there
as they're largely can play now and that
is largely complete at this stage yeah
okay
don't have any other questions of the
report something like to move it up Lee
received counseling ground duck and
signets thank you I'll put that motion
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried Thank You
counselors from policy and practices
over the past year comment b1 magnitude
this before we open for discussion thank
you
not really I was just under my name had
been prepared by the previous general
manager of regulatory services and I
only came to light recently that hadn't
been presented to the council so and it
does refer to the end of last financial
year June 2019 okay counselors I think
it's reason is self-explanatory
if there is no discussion with somebody
like to move this down proceed in
adoption place question think you wish
it I just wondered um this is this is
not particularly that but I'm just
wondering if the dog parks had been
completed did they come in on budget so
this you right relate to this report at
all I don't think there's anybody able
to give us an update on that at this
point in time I know that we can keep on
and come back to Council
whose permission Steve do you wanna make
a comment here to Santa where you
worship they were within budget I've had
no information to me to suggest they're
not but I can't give you a category Casa
much the other staff in the can because
Ian Soper was really in charge of those
two projects both matera and Gore I'm
not sure Donna whether you have had a
look at the costings they were off
memory there about $28,000 budgets
unfortunately there's something that I
don't have to hand at the moment and the
only thing I can contribute is that they
are complete there's still something
that I have to put the figures together
for the budget yeah thanks your worship
just a question answer but page 26
Bridget you've got registration fee
urban dog 120 - your AB&C
and me the next season's under there is
racially inclusive of babies should that
read exclusive because if you include
there you're saying this is just my
thinking I could be a bag of it excuse
that but so registration lease the lease
the fence control less the dogs unless
the neutered comes to comes to $60 you
pay registration 3 inclusive Arabian
seat should there be exclusive of agency
because of all was exclusive it means if
you don't if you don't have your feast
controlled if there's no complaints and
if there's no Spade at 60 but there's
it's exclusive of any of those then it's
150 AB&C
there are four more am i just nitpicking
hmm it's read wrong to be a dog couldn't
read it there are three times something
and it could be where I was brought up
it I think who you worship I think it's
it's a matter of interpretation what it
means to say that if you don't have a
fence and your dog not d6 and you've got
past this tree you get the whole feed
perhaps it can be worth a bitter I'm
more than happy to massage that so that
the readers under no sense of ambiguity
yeah I think so it would be great Steve
because just to me I've really inclusive
of ABC meaning if you've got a B and C
that's that's there's the fee above just
thanks good good point and you were sure
you were just that I haven't noticed the
record symbol on my iPad is it being
recorded the meaning yes it is oh that's
fine fine thank you
okay to move this be adopted received so
the grants seeking to counsel Mickey now
the motion which is green waste disposal
infrastructure and writing around the
green waste and how we are handling it
we really need to hit this signed off
tonight or or offered so that we can
carry on and doing what we currently are
doing and so who's going to speak to
this one is this better for you worship
is look I've just had overwhelming
thumbs up for the given with green waste
down at the transfer station has
actually it's been very busy
but actually the station's handling it
well the staff and the space we haveá--
so I suppose our thoughts here where
because we are making a change at the
end of June and to to free green waste
we're just concerned about the mixed
messages like coming back to payment and
being only for six weeks later to change
to free in so we were just thinking for
a number of reasons why this would be a
good time to actually so just continue
on with obviously there's a lot of
goodwill a moment towards council
especially with this we were people it's
a given a thumbs up to council when
we're down there so it's put in front of
you it might be a good thing just to
continue ok councils this is open for
discussion or adoption certainly the
feedback that I've had has been
overwhelmingly supportive of of the
process and the recognition the council
is making for some of the challenges
people have yeah I think he worship just
that we haven't had a formal discussions
about whether or not to bring most will
be carried on with matera and of under
free free dumping in Matera I've had
preliminary talks with the community
board and we we want to have open
discussion about about whether or not we
shut down the transfer station in Matera
in regards to greenways we're having an
on-site meeting on Sunday morning at
11:30 with the community board and
myself to bring forward some ideas to
ramesh about what we like to bring
forward in regards to the green waste
and also to the total recycling so I see
it in the recommendation that it's only
got transfer station at the moment so I
just like to put in a that we ever think
about material what we're going to do
for the future matera in regards to the
green waste and I believe that we should
the green waster matera because well you
may be able to come to go with your
groceries and bring a trailer and take
your green waste I think it's too
inconvenient for a reason town of the
size not to have a at least a green
waste dumping station good point and
well made and we have a discussion first
days but as far as I'm aware this
relates to the gore transfer station is
that right it probably needs some
clarity around that and you wish I think
the key point here is to this
recommendation really only applies from
now through to the end of June as we
have a separate resolution to take us
from 1 July onward a second key point is
that we're currently in moving from
level 3 to level 2 where there are still
expectations that
fearfully administered to prevent the
screening papers 19 virus so this is a
still on a temporary limited state and
as Council Phillip to see the wider
discussion about what type of service
delivery should be applied from terror
is beyond the reach of this particular
report but you see when we come back for
discussion that accounts level once it's
been through the board's deliberative
process so but my question my question
at the moment is even though we're going
we're going back into level 2 and we can
have some sort of control of green waste
in Matera why should it not continue so
from a practical perspective in terms of
the dealing with the volume of any green
waste all the control on the side
Peter do an amazing currently free
worship look at the moment of Inglis is
being run by volunteers for the Bourne
Club
and because of the age restrictions they
have been around aged workers and the
requirement that we have for track and
tracing just for simplicity and to the
end of this whole pandemic lockdown we
had decided bit we're just going to keep
Terra close but no decision has been
made at what point are we open okay look
I think the idea that has been put
forward that there's going to be a
discussion about the future with the
Community Board and the recommendation
coming back to council is probably the
best way forward now I'm on matera
rather than making a decision on the
hoop here and then finding that we can't
manage it quite as well as we'd we'd
planned but I'm open for a the other
conditions that might might come on okay
there's not right so we need to have a
recommendation that the report be
received and that council agree to free
disposal of green waste at the transfer
station which should read the gore
transfer station at this point with
matera yet to be formally and for the
next period for bovis thank you divert
signal for that that's I counselor Dixon
thinking is there any further discussion
on that one it's not emotional vocal
through so I change the motion is
carried on the next item can we meet can
we decide whether we're going to over
hands up physically or richland it's a
bit confusing just working out who's
doing what so from now on if if anybody
wants to ask a question can you please
put your hand up electronically or
virtually so I can see the list now
quite clearly but it's it's bit hard to
jump back and forth between screens and
Indian side so I've got you up there
tomorrow got cancer Phillips in
counselor high seed they live not okay
right no I just ask something
mm-hmm did you notice my hand up earlier
because I handed up for about five
minutes the chance so I'm sorry about
that Nikki I apologize ya know cuz I'm
just wondering if you can actually see
it it's not up but I'll put it on me on
the C makes you see it I can certainly
see there yeah thank you okay
your worship can we all please mute -
I'm getting flexed between Venus and
cliff and you went ape when pages get
turned it would be quite an ear for all
I'm you kept good point right let's move
on to the next item which is being
called surgery report and we've got a
three month's report going up to the
31st of March which janina's seems like
a an age away and certainly will be an
age away and gotta tell this computer
that what we're going forward but Steve
do you want to introduce this one who
are they speaking to this
you
yeah thanks you worship as you say it is
very historical and it does seem like a
lifetime ago I do know that mr. O Connor
the author of what is intending to
attend the next audit risk committee
meeting which is scheduled for 27 May
and I think will provide a somewhat of a
different story than what is portrayed
in this particular commentary and we we
certainly received daily updates as to
what is occurring in the marketplace and
the events in the world that generate
the the market behavior and I guess know
despite the strange times we live in the
market seem to be not really mirroring
and so sharp agree the kind of volatile
behavior that we have and some pipe some
parts of the world but we do live in
very strange times and as counsel make
the nail has noted that we're governed
by a policy in terms of our borrowings
but those policy settings may well be
due for further discussion and review
given these times were and and the
commentary around how long-term the very
low and threat environment we're in is
likely to to be with us so it may
actually the hope the council to review
once again its its policy settings and
but having said all those things if we
are doing a review it will have to go
through the special consultant procedure
and most likely would be profiled and
next year's long term plan Thank You
councillor host it yeah thanks your
worship yeah just the order and risk
committee when it last considered the
policy also was looking towards forming
a treasury advisory subcommittee to work
with the CFO in Bangkok
perhaps the independent member of audit
and risk until enables to be a lot more
bit more nimble and take advantage on a
particular circumstance and perhaps
enable variants and policies so on the
meeting of treason I'll certainly be
exploring that that again and hopefully
bring something back to Council because
it seems to take in a terrible amount of
time for being called to make minor
tweaks to the policy which was a wee bit
frustrating the last time we did it last
year okay because we're going on
yeah just a wee bit of concern with the
another swap being added on to the list
and I'm just running with it we
shouldn't do any more slots until we
have their ordered rest meeting on the
27th we have a reason recently for
discussion about their good I can't see
the reason for taking the other swap
their interest rate hmm okay so I'm just
going back to how we can change that
policy and the comments you made Steve
about so a special consultant precision
does that reflect what John's suggesting
in that might have to happen if we did
make a change
your liability policy is one of those
sweeter policies that gets reviewed
every three years through your long-term
plan I'd need to just check on what the
absolute content of that policy is
relative to how much detail it goes into
but in principle if you if you amend
that policy it has to be through a
consultation process and most councils
to do that every three years and any
tweaking 'he's going to LTP and the
affords available for the public to make
comment on but the the order of rescue
mode II have debated quite at length the
ratio between sex versus floating and
just rate exposure and that off the top
of my head and I haven't passed in front
of me as often a cornerstone of your
liability policy that is reviewed every
three years okay I'll take the point
that counsel Goins making and something
if we're going to avoid incurring cost
by making changes like this we should
but we do need to make sure that we're
doing is doing it correctly as well
counselor doesn't need a question yes
I'm just wondering the I see that we
have a committed bank facility at the
ANC bank for three million and it
expires on the 20th of June will we be
rolling it over or will it we're going
to utilize it somehow there's guards
electrician probably Donna um at the
stage I know we're of what we are doing
with it um my apologies I have to look
under there
I canceled out on Newcastle hosting that
Bank facilities costing us about 33,000
a year
oh I just wanted with it should we ever
make she used it for quite a while with
appreciation we choose to go into 1
million or we should discuss it at the
or in risk and depth I think major quite
an intense discussion on that and using
changing their slots and using bonds for
lengthy swapping things Ram I think we
need to have a real good discussion on
the whole whole situation still staying
within their policy you did write the
right venue and time for this as sort of
meeting for a discussion and then if any
council it's not on that committee and
wants to be part of it then they
certainly can be so that can happen
given input councillor heisted yeah I
guess I need to respond to a couple of
things because written risk it's been a
quite a bit of time on the on aging
profile firstly on page 39 you'll see
the reason why the latest swap was taken
their policy requires us to stay with
those bands so we don't want staff
guessing what they need to do the policy
inform staff there at that point they
need to take a hitch or a swap to stay
within policy so that's that's the first
thing I think we should clarify secondly
calling swaps a cost that there are
insurance and you just comparing the
floating rate to fixed rate in fixed
rates at this stage you're more
expensive that is deemed to be prudent
that the council doesn't have a live
simple it's well the state's rating that
might be wrong but unfortunately that is
their their policy and it has a level of
prudence so well they're more expensive
it's an insurance premium it's not
necessarily a cost because you're just
comparing to the borrowing them floating
rates and in terms of swaps versus bonds
the cost is very similar but the reason
we take swaps as it allows us to
anticipate the bonds do not allow you to
do that we have a capital expenditure
program in front of us
that we need to anticipate adhering to
our policy because that policy requires
us to not only fixed existing the
projected deep and you can't do that
necessarily easily with bombs so hence
the swaps are out there and they are a
synthetic so they do a pair liability so
I'll probably bored you enough but you
just recent your audit risk here but sit
on their hands in this one thank you
cancel I said I think that's that's a
timely in Egyptian or observation in I
think we we do need to bear in mind that
we do have this audit and Risk Committee
that is functioning and it's functioning
well in in my opinion and it's there to
protect counsel and the right place on
our long-term basis rather than a
knee-jerk basis but I also hear the call
for being flexible and being able to be
nimble and do what we can so that really
a discussion at ordered and risk with
the relevant people in the room who can
advise us properly is the time to be
making those decisions probably not now
councilman turnout you to question your
on new truck
they are they do cost you cash they are
costing us about four hundred grand a
year and extra interest as it today if
you calculate it out and that's a
sizable chunk of the council's revenue
going out in the moment I know it's
historic but if you continue to do it
you could just Cooney to pay money away
that you don't have to because the
interest rates are going to stay low for
a long time and there are other
mechanisms and we can discuss about how
to around us without cause and the
council undue risk but we'll leave that
ordered and risk there any other
questions I can't see any other hands
there at this point in time if not what
somebody like to move that the Treasury
report the be received and notice
councillor grant and
council budget Thank You Cindy loads in
favor please say aye
please Thank You counsel
we'll move on then to revenue and
forecasting or revenue forecasting for
the year 30 June which is sort of a
difficult one right at the moment but we
have a memo here from the chief chief
executive with a list of we're things up
and down or mainly down so but Steve do
you want to make any comment to the
reporting I you thanks for worship we
thought we'd do this report just so that
for as much as their own curiosity
obviously as elected members about where
we think we might land with these
extraordinary times that we find
ourselves in and as the report really
touches on the real area of risk is the
swimming pool and or multi Motor Sports
Complex where a decent amount of revenue
is derived from these charges and
admissions ironically a lot of councils
that have had quite extensive forays and
other activities have experienced a lot
more acute problems than ourselves but
in the main it's really really including
parking and obviously these building and
resource consent fees are down but the
Motorsports complex is the main one we
think these is ahead they're the key
thing that this report was prepared by
Donna not knowing as to what level two
would look like and not know when they
were to level two would arrive so
there's a little bit of an opportunity
now for some of the bleeding in regard
to your loss of revenue to be
apprehended in part by being able to
open and part a building in planning are
still open for business and have
conduct themselves throughout the
lockdown although that jacket released
those two activities were quite very
quite quiet sitting during Locke level
for parking will resume next week not
that we're going to be going out there
with an overzealous attitude and
likewise the Paul Levin Center will be
able to open and part but still won't be
able to recover the type of ground that
was lost at the last six weeks and nor
will it may be normal activity resumed
and I guess we also need to factor in
their people may well be cautious and
they opted to vote with their feet
initially which could see a further
reduction and patronage of the multi
Sports Center
thank you Steve so this report is open
for discussion or question and it is a
bit of a stab in the dark at this point
in time but certainly the trends
particularly the model SportsCenter are
not looking their flesh in terms of
income wasn't year councillor Bolger if
I've got my hand up it's a mistake
say councillor council host a Tracy yeah
I think I've got two questions first one
is just in relation to we've examined
revenue over the next nine months or for
the mine once to 31 match if staff
turned their mind to to cost you don't
know that's very difficult but if we are
facing a revenue reduction are we just
taking it on the nose or are these some
measures here will be reviewed around
costs as they progress to Donna or to
the executive I'm not sure
yes I can you wish it no cost has
certainly been looked at there has been
quite a stringent drive to remove cost
if we can without being too shall we say
self harming in our outlook but of
course we made the call to to make
redundant the swim instructors was at
that stage martin their manager had said
look he counts he did operating and
until level one and level one from our
view was quite a way away Martin at
non-sports complex has gone through and
really tried to efficiently run that
facility as as much as he can and some
councils will be aware that we were even
looking at potentially having an adverse
effect on the neighboring ice rink just
to try and keep those costs as low as
possible
so that certainly yeah it's not just in
the motor sports complex across the
board we are looking at what we can do
to save money and that is not just for
this financial year it's reflected in
our budgeting for next year which that
should be the subject of a public
discussion and they come to try and
drive down cost a look at what how we
can save to minimize the impact the
right path thank you I had a second part
to my question now this is this is a
long row but I'm hoping that you'll let
me take this angle if procurement policy
sort of close requirement bossy and I'm
thinking here about ensuring that the
emphasis on by local as appropriate in
any a policy yeah what would it be
appropriate that the we get a report
from the chief executive reasonably soon
just around that ensuring that we're
putting emphasis on local I know he
hasn't been met long ago we reviewed it
but
just in the current environment every
dollar we can spend in a tip on as long
as it value for money would probably can
I just get some clarification do you
want report on the application of the
policy or the review of the policy
settings a little bit of both like yes
how helps actually working and if you
could see any potential to increase
emphasis without putting an undue cost
on council right and you may don't we
have already done there because it's
quite a recent just I think the
community needs to know that we are
seriously considering all ever news that
we can spin locally just a business good
point and is this means see it already
it's not that long ago that we went
through this with a fine-tooth comb and
and made some quite big changes to it
but it would be good to see what the
application of those changes looks like
and are there any opportunities for
refinement along the way so ok
Chancellor Reed thank you your worship
I'm just a question for Steve what the
changes that the government made to the
wage subsidy applications heavily
applied to that for the pool for the
closure because of the limit before but
intellect $30,000 loss bracket through
your worship it's our intention to do so
for the Motorsports complex I can't tell
you exactly where their application is I
know mass and micariff the manager is
worth was working on it there's no
guarantee that we'll get it but my
argument is that if you look at that
facility and isolation has suffered a 30
percent drop in income for what will be
three months maybe ond and so it's
worthy of us putting forward an
application and that was the latest
advice that we got
from the local governments expert
think-tank in Wellington
so that's your intention but I can't
tell you exactly where that is that it
was under development about a week ago
Donna do you have any information about
whether Martens completed the
application
I don't believe where is at that point
at this stage I'm still asleep in talks
with working income to verify whether we
can do this on a dependent basis thank
you yes yes this is a curriculum the
biggest potential for loss and reviews
the co-chair writes the furrows game
which is a great scheme and I know Steve
you here you want to do it with an
existing but there's no I just wonder if
it's pretty optimistic in somewhere
along the line on I imagine you're
considering if you'd have to borrow some
money we've just talked about air swaps
policy I guess you'll keep us informed
as to he'll you're gonna take a little
see the debt thing something that's
gonna rear its ugly he'd and that makes
three months well today I can tell you
that the take-up has been quite light on
that particular scheme it's alive and
kicking so it's not posing any problem
at this point in time we did can make a
commitment that would report monthly to
the council I would visit that we would
do our first report on that scheme next
month as reported last month we have the
cash in the system we thought that would
be able to manage the deferrals through
that certainly if the current take-up
continues it won't pose any problems but
it's a matter of just monitoring at
month by month and we'll see what the
impact is and whether it is going to be
a bigger issue then walk with this door
thank you see Brahmin you still get your
hand up is it from previously yeah okay
would somebody like to move that that
report be received in counselor hosted
seconded counselor flips is there any
operation or discussion required there's
not put the motion all those in favor
please say aye Gaines the motion is
carried
thank you councilors item T and health
and safety report we have a health and
safety report from human resources
manager reasonably straightforward and
just a note there the fertility of the
oxidation ponds which been notified by
WorkSafe that they will lay charges
against the council so that matter is
now subject to a judicial process and we
can't discuss that further in this forum
but it's open for discussion that item
in councillors is there any questions or
queries of other human resources manager
there's not at this point with somebody
like to move that it be received just
Nick Nick grant thank you over the
signature council Reed thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councilors item 11 and we have
an annual report from civic financial
services and a memo from chief executive
Steve do you want to make any comment -
this one's not really weird about
boundary okay so I think it's reasonably
self-explanatory and it's and they had a
sale of death of the building through
this period which is given quite a boost
I have to say but it's open for
discussion so there's no discussion with
somebody like to move your seat please
answer Bolger cygnets cancel Phillips
thank you
snow for the discussion I'll put that
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors item 12 the first expansion
of the urban rating boundaries and we
have a memo from the chief executive
with a with a proposal to or
recommendation and to defer that rating
venue boundary review until the 2223
financial year just given some of the
pressures that the community is under
and what it might do to some of these
boundaries that would shift across from
where they are currently there but Steve
do you want to make a comment before we
open this for discussion you think your
worship the key point here is to
emphasize that there is no financial
disadvantage the council in postponing
this particular policy decision of the
council and I'm wanting sizes
postponement not cancellation we're all
geared and have done a little work and
actually preparing for the instruction
of the new rating boundaries and led us
to go to the reasons bear in mind that
has been a couple years now since this
issue was passionately debate at the
last iteration of the long term plan but
I felt that really that know some of
these properties are going to have quite
a shift and rating incidents and at this
time where there is households are under
some households are under strain and
uncertainty it seemed to me that would
possibly be a poor timing on the
council's part and maybe a two-year
deferral to then pick up the process at
that time would be a more compassionate
stance the council then just carrying on
full speed ahead so it really is
a metaphor the council to give a green
light or red light to and I say as I say
there's no financial penalty either way
apart from the fact that the ratepayers
will find in terms of rates moving out
of rural zone into urban zone which in
some cases would be possibly an increase
of $1,000 or more on a radius history
thank you Steve and so this item is now
open for discussion but certainly from
my perspective I think this this is a
good suggestion and one that will ease
some burden of these a potential burden
and that we have semental and so on so
open for discussion and or
recommendation so do I have a any
comment from councillors councillor
Bolger councillor hi Steve
yeah I think it's a good idea to defer
it you start adjusting the rating policy
sometimes you just you have unintended
consequences and you've got to do it
quite gently and give yourself a wee bit
of time to remedy something that's
popped up unexpectedly obviously we will
have to expand the urban rating boundary
in time but I think the supporters
approach has certainly the correct way
to go at the moment if they see worship
I'm you know I think everyone around the
table was is potentially conflict or
impacted by this but I am in particular
a property that will be and Peter so I
have no comment on this but just just
thinking about this rating islands and
industry connected to urban services I'm
just wondering if it will be appropriate
at the alongside this to ask the CEO to
prepare report just reflecting on the
consistency between between Gore matera
and rural for industry connected to
urban services the appropriateness just
to be clear I'm not suggesting any rate
increase or change and rating
to those those industries but just tell
those those rates fall into two urban
and in rural and I'd like the at some
stage in the near future to see a report
from the CEO just just reflecting on
that yep goodbye okay
Chancellor Davis you think you wish it
yes I agree with counselor Bolger that
it's timely that we pause with with
interviewing with us at the moment a lot
of pressure on households and in a
change for some could be quite
devastating at the moment so I think
it's very timely and a good idea to
press pause on this and following on
from Council heisted I think it would be
prudent for us to see what health health
large industries are rated in whether
it's fear across the board foot or how
they're rated and we'll be good to get
some further information on that so I
support his stance on me okay okay
councillor grant duck yeah thanks your
worship
actually yeah totally agree with the
last three councillors councillor Bolger
correct and then yeah you can't we just
can't roll this thing out now but we
also need to as councilor high stair
suggested we need to figure out we're
what these industries that are doing and
the if they're connected to the urban
sewage system or water system and and
then have a reports that fully fully
back up those two last additions things
okay councillor read and then caster go
on thank you worship yeah I agree with
cliff and also the proposal I think it's
a good one that we just just have to be
careful and easily
towards that change and shift this is
definitely not the right time so I'm
completely an agreement or there and I
like the idea of a review as well I
think that's probably quite timely it
gives us a little bit of time before we
actually make those proposed changes of
if that's necessary thank you thank you
John services but they do pay for them
and but we do have to take into account
they do have an effect on the rule
writing because I love my brain stocking
and milk and from the rule writing and
if they have things cut if making the
rule saw it so I totally agree with with
a review of the rating Ireland's works
you expanding that request a wee bit
further now but I think it's probably
quite timely so is there anybody else
wants to make any comment for hands up
the stage yes
okay mr. Dixon um thank you worship
look I just like to support this
recommendation in but also support and
even distribute eight evenly distribute
the urban-rural rates for those
businesses that are outside the urban
area I think and I do support a report
on that because I think it is timely as
well okay right so don't see cancel all
good news
yes issue worship it's it's seems to be
the sort to gather you know some of
industries that are recently rated as
rural industries into the
and to the urban warden it's very
generous offer but of course I'll take
their counselor guidelines point you
know some of those industries also then
queue costs which are imposed on on real
ratepayers so once again it's not just
get too complicated by all means have a
review it just find it we were going to
land but it's a if you try to alter the
more things you call it okay one time
the more opportunities arose to the
things to go things to go awry I guess
this will call it a debate let's call it
the discussions really be prompted by
matera belly Milken and their impact on
the community and in it it's been well
pointed out in the pasture they do use
urban infrastructure services but they
kept they pay they pay for that access
and so they and probably pay a little
bit over there over the cost so I would
by all means have review but I'd really
is some some caution there with just
making too expensive all true radical
change all at the one time yeah
click the point that council Bob's
making and I guess we're going to be
careful not to make assumptions as to
what might happen or what even the
magnate motivation for this reviewers
but the original release proven one case
that I said was to just having a look at
rating islands and see if they're
filling the the role that we created
them for effect I think we've only got
one from my understanding which is
matera the heavy industry rating on down
here but the discussions go on further
to took commercial and industrial
operators that are no matter where they
are
are they being rated fairly is that is
that what we're asking for it is quite a
big review I've suggested and maybe got
a Steve do you want to make a comment
here in terms of the practicalities of
the size of what we're asking evil
yes thank you worship I well I don't see
it being a huge review like I mean it's
it's timely
I would probably approach it in two
bites and so I think first first of all
would be report around what is our
rating current rating practice and
philosophy when it comes to major
industry and what are some of the
commonalities and what are some of the
peculiarities and then I would probably
pull to that point open it for a
discussion or maybe a workshop around to
see if we can further refine what the
problem is and then work away from that
point onwards okay
Thank You council hosted I think
yesterday's you know things just to
clarify I was asking Berlin's
inconsistency between Gore matera and
rule because we do have one example it
seems to be quite isolated and just as
you same decision make some information
for councillors to consider No Agenda
the donors are you just following on
from there I was just going to reply to
councillor Bolger and just say that it's
let's wait and see because we'll get the
review and we'll have a workshop around
what that presents to us and in as a
council we will make some decisions I
suppose whether we're doing that
correctly and we're happy with with how
things are looking or whether we need to
make some changes but I think it is
timely thank you okay
so there are other comments or questions
and my understanding of what's being
suggested is that we're asking for a
review of the consistency consistency
and a appropriateness of the heavy
industry brady garland that we currently
have and and how it's a help could be or
is apportioned across the district under
the future so if I'm correct there with
something like to move in that direction
accountable host it thank you to have a
seconder for that counsel board thank
you
is there any further discussion
does not I put that emotional those in
favor please say aye
Gaines the motion is carried Thank You
counselors I actually I we needed to
extend that I'm sorry I just need to go
back one second we've moved that we're
going to have a review the
recommendation that came from the urban
rating boundary a report was that we
defer we deferred so we actually need to
move that that motion as well somebody
like to move that that be adopted Dixon
thank you signet counselor Reid thank
you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you okay councillors I think that
brings us to the end of the open agenda
we do have some business to be
transacted in committee excluded from
the following parts of the Proceedings
of this meeting and only the items
listed below confirmation of minutes
from extraordinary meetings confirmation
of minutes from the ordinary meaning of
council health 15 April confirmation the
minutes of council and committee meeting
held 22 April other business update on
land negotiations water treatment plants
upgrade work so first the gore District
Council and hell Road Bridge would
somebody like to second that we discuss
those in committee Thank You councillor
Bolger all those in favor please say aye